après 15 ans de polémique et de bataille
juridique le minaret Haus de 25 m de la
2e mosquée de France se profile dans le
paysage lyonnais son financement près de
20 milliards de francs a été assuré en
grande partie par le roi d'Arabie
Saoudite plus de 2500 musulmans ont
assisté cet après-midi à la prière du
vendredi quelques heures après
l'inauguration de cette mosquée par
Charles pascoy ministre chargé des
cultes qui a lancé l'idée d'un concordat
entre l'Islam et la France reportage
Marc Maisonneuve Françoise Valley
avec émotion pour la première fois il
pris ensemble dans la mosquée de Lyon
plus de 2500 musulmans sont venus
consacrer sans doute la plus grande
salle de prière d'une mosquée en France
c'est le grand MF le premier imam du
lieu qui prêche aujourd'hui c le Coran
il évoque la construction de la toute
première mosquée un symbole à Lyon les
musulmans ont attendu 15 ans ce
moment
est joli c'est formidable on est fier on
est fier d'avoir un mosquée à Lyon on
est on est content toujours musulman
égal intégriste enfin musulman égal
français et sympathique et j'espère même
que beaucoup de Français pourront venir
ici prier avec nous comme nous si ça
leur convient ils veulent que la mosquée
soit un lieu de paix et défendent un
islam tolérant on fait trop de politique
dans la mais a des extrêmes il existe il
faut les combattre c'est tout de la même
façon com absolument mais bien sûr il n'
aucune place avec par
et c'est bien ce message de fermeté qu'a
voulu donner le ministre de l'Intérieur
ce matin pour l'inauguration officielle
c'est la deème mosquée construite en
France et quand Charles pascoy entre
dans l'histoire il y entre en chaussette
musulman ou pas le seul moyen de
pénétrer dans la salle de prière d'une
mosquée le discours est modérateur mais
la fermeté est
là
l'islam est aujourd'hui une réalité
française parce que c'est pour une
grande part une religion de français
aussi ne saurait-il plus seulement y
avoir un islam en France il doit y avoir
un islam de France est-ce que vous
traitez avec les modérés parce que vous
pouvez pas traiter avec les
autres je traite pas avec les modérés je
traite avec les gens qui sont
représent inchallah comme dit le
ministre de l'Intérieur rendant un
hommage appuyé à ce qu'il appelle de ses
vux l'islam de France la deè religion du
pays une religion sous haute
surveillance